you know normally I get annoyed when the
video I was planning to release on a day
gets bumped because of something coming
out that I have to talk to right away
but when it's this good I'm okay with it
so yeah I was gonna put out my latest
Doctor Who list today but instead we got
the new full trailer for a black panther
so yeah I'm gonna talk about that and I
like it quite a bit actually oddly I
like it more than I feel like I should
because we don't actually get a whole
lot of plot from it which for the record
I'm totally fine with I like not knowing
a ton about what's gonna happen story
wise and these things before I get into
them but the thing is it's weird cuz I
feel like we got more plot from the
teaser than we did from this
quote-unquote full trailer and that
strikes me as a little bit odd it's also
very action beat heavy which also feels
more teaser ish than full trailer as and
I also feel like if this had been the
teaser if this had come out first I
probably wouldn't like it as much but
somehow I think maybe it's just we got
just enough foundational stuff going
with the teaser that I'm just kind of
drinking in getting a feel for the
spectacle in this and it's spectacle of
two kinds there's action spectacle which
normally I'd be berating the fact that
it looks like it's a little CGI heavy
but there's two things about that that
appear to be that appear to work at
least in what I've seen so far number
one black panther suit lends itself to
CGI because he is completely covered
it's like Iron Man suit you can go full
CGI and you avoid the uncanny valley cuz
you're not seeing his actual face you
don't have to replicate that I also feel
like they're using CGI in action the way
that it is best used which is to do
things that it is impossible to do any
other way so when you've got him you
know getting knocked aside by claws you
know sonic cannon um he's got he's
rocking that which I like so he gets not
excited but that and then runs up a
building and leaks back down onto these
cars well there's no possible way to do
that anyway other than CGI so when
you're inventive
enough to do sequences that cannot be
done any other way and you have got
either CGI that is good enough or you've
got little tricks like the fact that
he's in a full suit and you don't have
to recreate human flesh to to make this
CGI look as good as this looks that is a
better perfect combination for some
great action set-pieces but that's not
the only kind of spectacle because we
get to see more of what Conda and I am
loving everything I see about Wakanda it
does such a good job of telling us
visually a story of a society that is
separate from at least from anything I
know speaking as a white middle-class
American but it feels very much it it
reminds me of Lord of the Rings I'm
looking at the costumes and the sets and
the weapons and I feel like it's all
designed to tell a story
it's everything that the Inhumans should
have been doing and failed to do in
terms of showing a city of a completely
different society that's been cut off
from the rest of humanity so I am really
digging this whole look of Wakanda and
I'm liking how many different scenes
we're sort of seeing there it gives me
the impression that we're gonna get a
lot of stuff set there which I like
because what I don't want to happen what
usually tends to happen with the more
fantastical place is it gets sidelined
usually because it's really expensive to
do that's why so much of the first Thor
is set on earth that's what happened
with OA and Green Lantern heck that's
that's a part of why we only get so much
Krypton in any given Superman movie so
I'm getting the impression that we're
gonna get a lot more of Wakanda than we
usually get from these sorts of settings
in these kinds of stories which I also
like I'm loving the vibe I get off
Michael B Jordan he's got a he's got a
viciousness about him and it feels very
motivated I don't know exactly what his
deal is exactly what he's after why but
I feel like this is a guy who believes
in what he's doing is just it's just a
vibe it's just to me about the
expressions on his face and the
determination in his lines loving that
Andy Serkis I already mentioned loved
having him back I always loved Andy
Serkis
I just I really I'm not
the best trail I've ever seen it's not a
perfect trail or anything but I actually
I don't have anything I want I feel like
I need to complain about I I feel like
this is just a really great trailer and
again I this might be this is probably
gonna be the last Black Panther trailer
I'm going to watch because I'm now 100%
absolutely sold totally looking forward
to this and like I said I like that it
doesn't tell me too much more about the
plot I don't want to know more about the
plot because I'm gonna see it already so
anything else that I see is just gonna
be spoiling stuff whether it's major or
minor I want to know as little as
possible from right here so this will
probably the last YC I like it it pump
me oh you know what a big part of how
this pump me up the music great song
selection and great integration of the
music with the visuals and it cuz it
felt like the trailer was in beat and it
didn't feel like it was that way because
of heavy cutting to force it that way
just something about them just married
really well it was it was just a real
fist pumping kind of vibe that I get
that had got at the end of this trailer
and a big part of that was the was the
song choice the music selection I am
really excited about this movie I think
this could be amazingly good and and
interestingly not in in a way that I
thought superhero movies were gonna have
to be for me cuz I was starting to get
the feeling I'm really only gonna get
really pumped about these things when
they can be different from like okay yes
it's a superhero movie but what else is
it I mean that's a big part of why the
the new moons trailer really kind of
enticed me but this really does look
like a pretty much a straightforward
superhero movie in terms of you know the
real nuts and bolts of the narrative but
if it can if they can be delivered with
this much style with a cast that is this
game for it with this much of a unique
vision I'm actually excited for for what
appears to be a fairly straightforward
superhero movie I wasn't sure I still
had that in me I'm on board I thought
this was great what were your thoughts
on the black panther trailer whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher
I'm also on half of the punch like a
girl podcast that is on the fire and
water podcast network
Fire & Water podcast calm and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]